are we asking the right questions are we
still in this old mindset where we think
it's all about overpopulation
because it's not
hi i'm zach weissmuller for reason tv
we're coming to you from the tribeca
film festival in new york i'm here with
jessica yoo
the academy award-winning filmmaker
behind the new documentary
misconception an examination of the
facts
and myths behind the global
overpopulation debate
i do meet people who are scared about
population growth
but they haven't understood you don't
need to
control population numbers this is a
myth
politicians need to come down to the
ground see the people themselves
overpopulation is a subject that grabs
headlines
um it's sensational it's scary in your
documentary you kind of build it around
the
ideas and writings of han's wrestling
what first attracted you
to roslin's ideas and why did you decide
that
he would kind of be the center point of
the documentary
talking about misconceptions i mean i
think the first one was that
we were kind of making that that
assumption that population
meant overpopulation and when we first
started researching
the topic rosling's ted talks came up
and i felt like every single time i
watched one
some basic assumption that i had made
about the world was
being turned on its head and so that
became kind of a thematic basis for the
film
you've done uh previous documentaries
about running out of resources
was your mind changed at some point talk
about your perspective coming into it
and your perspective at the end of
making it
yeah the film about the water crisis is
called last call the oasis
and when we were making this film we
were thinking about the role of
population growth
and at every screening in the q a
someone would stand up and say
why are we even talking about
conservation when we can't control
population growth you know you guys need
to make a film about population so kind
of coincide with what our thoughts were
i don't think i was fully thinking you
know the population bomb
the rockets heading off the graph and i
don't think i was
thinking in apocalyptic terms
necessarily but
i do think that i was thinking still
very much in terms of numbers
and so i think probably the biggest
turn that came in my mind and it was
something that i tried to replicate in
the film because i think that's the way
that these kind of films work best is
when you remember what surprised you
what made you
have a different perspective was this
idea that
it's not about adjusting the numbers
and making people conform to the numbers
and that's how you solve people's
problems it's the exact opposite
you broke the movie into three chapters
each in a different part of the world
each kind of exemplifying a different
aspect of this debate
and the first chapter was set in china
where it's
very well known at this point that the
one child policy
has been a giant backfire lots
of social problems there you follow a 29
year old
man who is searching for a wife
in a pool where there aren't as many
single women as there are single men
do you think that governments are going
to keep
trying to do these kinds of things to
control the population
and should they be doing anything along
those lines
i think that there will always be
governments that will
intervene in a way that will prove to
have unintended consequences and that's
what that story is about
um yes you know pop fertility numbers
dropped but
there are a lot of um other issues that
that came up and now
of course china's trying to relax the
policy but you know hans rosaling says
you know fertility rates dropped in
china not just because of the one child
policy
there's other places in asia where
fertility also dropped it's also about
access to family planning
it's about economic opportunity and so
these young women they don't necessarily
want to get married at 22 and go live
with their
husbands family they want to have their
uh education their careers
and maybe they want to get married when
they're 30. but this is the 30 year old
man who
want to marry the 22 year old so it's
like this
love triangle dynamic that's being
played out on a national scale in these
urban centers and there's a lot of
pressure on
on young people and also on the
traditional mindset you're talking about
kind of the individual choices that
people are making that
governments aren't able to predict
necessarily
and you document a lot of top-down
approaches like that whether it's the
chinese policy or
governments giving away cars to have
people sterilize themselves or
give away cars to have people have more
babies what is the role
of personal choice in solving
or kind of abating the overpopulation
right so the example of giving away cars
is i think a perfect example
of a disconnect the people who
participate in
these kind of campaigns you know they
get sterilized they get a chance to win
a little car
they have more babies in russia they
have a chance to win a big car
if you talk to those families as we did
they were going to make those decisions
anyway it didn't have anything to do
with the chance at winning a vehicle
so i think again it's looking at what do
people really need what do they really
want
so when we're looking at individual
choices and what people need
if you look at the example in uganda
it's it's really about the basics it's
about having
access to education health care it's
autonomy
it's a poverty alleviation it's all the
basics
i think the film is about trying to look
at the issue
from a different perspective and to ask
ourselves are we are we
asking the right questions are we still
in this old mindset where we think it's
all about overpopulation
because it's not what was really
striking in the movie
is the way that when women's choices in
particular
are constrained the fertility rate goes
up
what role does expanding the individual
rights of women and protecting women's
rights in particular
play into this debate when women have
access to more choices
it doesn't mean that they stop having
kids and it doesn't mean that
they're necessarily going to have uh
more more kids what we find is that
when women have access to again all the
things that you need to have a decent
chance at life
they tend to gravitate towards two
children per woman
obviously there's some variation but i
think what you see is that in giving
more opportunity
it's a stabilizing influence i think
there's a there also is a is a
misconception about the idea that if
people have
maybe more recesses so more opportunity
that they're going to have more kids
that somehow there's a darwinian thing
going on if you deny things from people
then they'll have fewer kids because
they can't take care of them
that's not how it works the fear that
people have about
overpopulation often is that in these
other countries whether it's india or
china
that they're just going to keep growing
and they're going to consume all the
earth's resources
that doesn't seem to be accurate i think
in wealthier countries
there tends to be a lot of hand-wringing
about
high fertility rates people having too
many babies because somehow we think
that's going to take away from what we
have
but really what we should be concerned
about is that high fertility rates
happen in places where that's an
indication that there
is a lot of suffering on the ground in a
lot of places a lot of countries in
sub-saharan africa which
uh very high poverty levels women don't
have a lot of choices
people tend it's almost like a visceral
darwinian kind of
instinct people have to try to just uh
you know it's it's fearful i think for
them to think about the masses
that fearful kind of visceral reaction
given that it's so ingrained in human
nature really to think about
things as just a shrinking pie
is there any way to overcome that and
how does it
affect how we think about these issues
it's a
great question because i think that that
fear
it doesn't inform the bait it actually
prevents the debate we hide behind fear
it's
such an it's a way to be able to um
avoid dealing with the problem because
if something is scary and it's
overwhelming and there's nothing you can
do
then you can back away so i think uh
taking the cue from hans rosling the
idea is wait a minute let's look at what
we're really dealing with
you thought it was this big scary thing
that's not actually what's happening
there are these pockets where there's
things need to change there's other
things that actually are doing quite
well let's
really take a realistic look so i think
in that way um
there's something that can be very
helpful just about
basic knowledge and i think that was one
thing that was really eye-opening is to
realize
some very basic things about what's
happening
in the world right now that are not um
that are not widely known and it drives
hans crazy
the movie is misconception premiering at
tribeca jessica you thank you very much
for talking to us
it's been a pleasure thank you for
reason tv i'm zach weissmuller